we still know very little about what's
in store for 2021's new ghostbusters
sequel ghostbusters afterlife but we're
very excited about what's next here's
what we know so far about director jason
reitman's foray into a new neighborhood
with something strange
the first reports of jason reitman's
involvement in a new ghostbusters film
arrived in january 2019. reitman soon
confirmed via his twitter account that
the film would hit theaters on july 10th
2020. then covet 19 happened and
ghostbusters afterlife has been moved
back multiple times since the film was
initially bumped to march 5th 2021 then
a new release date of june 11 2021 was
set after those both fell through sony
moved the release date back first to
november 11th then to november 19th that
would seem to be the date that will
finally stick it seems like a lifetime
ago now but when the initial teaser that
announced the film dropped in january
2019 didn't give a title fans simply
started referring to the upcoming film
as ghostbusters 2020 assuming that the
movie would actually come out that year
the title remained a mystery until
december 2019 when the british board of
film classification which has to approve
all trailers in the uk revealed that the
approval notice for the new trailer gave
the title ghostbusters afterlife it's an
appropriate title given that the film is
not only about ghosts but also about
legacy
reitman has noted that his idea for the
film began with a 12 year old girl
carrying a proton pack and that image
ultimately expanded to include a whole
family that 12 year old phoebe will be
played by mckenna grace a rising young
talent who's been seen in everything
from captain marvel to chilling
adventures of sabrina to the haunting of
hill house carrie [ __ ] who's shown her
talents in tv series like fargo and the
leftovers as well as films like gone
girl and avengers infinity war plays
phoebe's mother callie finn wolfhard
who's probably best known for stranger
things and the it movies plays phoebe's
brother trevor in september 2019
producer ivan reichman revealed comedy
superstar turned superhero paul rudd's
role in the film saying he's a
seismologist who's come to this small
town because they've been having
mysterious earthquakes the earthquakes
are likely tied to paranormal events
rudd's character mr gruberson also ends
up working as a summer school teacher
likely creating his connection with the
family at the film's center
in june 2019 sigourney weaver seemed to
confirm in an interview that she was
indeed reprising her role as dana
barrett she said it's going to be crazy
working with the guys again either i
have a monster in my kitchen or i'm
completely crazy
i don't think you're crazy
oh good that makes me feel so much
better those guys
are obviously bill murray dan aykroyd
and ernie hudson aykroyd confirmed in
september 2019 that he would be
returning to the franchise along with
most of the original people by the end
of 2019 murray hudson and annie potts
were also all confirmed to be on board
in early 2020 vanity fair ran a report
from the set of afterlife while the
publication was strictly banned from
revealing anything about the plot an
extended conversation with murray
confirmed that something special was in
store for the iconic characters he said
the script is good it's got lots of
emotion in it it's got lots of family in
it with through lines that are really
interesting it's gonna work
jason reitman's feature film directorial
career began in 2005 with thank you for
smoking since then he's become known for
a particular style that often walks the
line between comedy and drama in films
like juno up in the air tully young
adult and most recently the front runner
his films are often small in scale
exploring the intimacy and absurdity of
human relationships rather than big set
pieces his comedy usually comes out of
interaction between characters rather
than gangs though he's undoubtedly
formed his own writing and directing
style reitman's interest in filmmaking
has its roots in family he's the son of
actress genevieve robert and writer
director ivan reitman who notably
directed the original ghostbusters and
ghostbusters 2. the ghostbusters
franchise is an integral part of jason
reitman's life he even had a cameo in
the 1989's ghostbusters 2 when he was
around 11 years old
you know my dad said you guys are full
of crap a sci-fi comedy about ghost
hunters isn't exactly in line with his
previous films but when it was announced
that he would helm afterlife his
familial ties to the franchise helped it
all make sense
it took a while to see more than a few
images related to reitman's new take on
ghostbusters and what we did see
consistently leaned heavily on nostalgia
the first teaser begins with a wide shot
of a large metal building in the middle
of a wooded area the camera pushes in
closer and closer to the door eventually
revealing the ghostbusters old ride
ecto-1 just sitting in storage the first
real trailer arrived in early december
2019. it largely follows the two kids at
the heart of the story trevor and phoebe
as they get used to their new life at
their inherited farmhouse in a small
oklahoma town but things get weird when
an eerie green light starts to emit from
an old pit outside of town mr gruberson
explains they're also experiencing weird
seismic activity that there's no logical
explanation for then the kids finally
bring an old ghost trap they found in
their farmhouse school and mr gruberson
realizes they must have a connection to
the ghostbusters it's revealed that
there hasn't been a real ghost sighting
in three decades and the ghostbusters
once regarded as heroes are now
forgotten legends phoebe and trevor
begin to seek out more information about
their long-lost grandfather who owned
the farmhouse the trailer reveals he was
indeed dr egon spengler one of the
original ghostbusters while the trailer
doesn't have any new footage of the
returning ghostbusters cast it does
provide a nostalgic kick by playing bill
murray's speech about fate from the 1984
original call it
faith call it lock call it karma
i believe that everything happens for a
reason the second trailer released in
july 2021 has much of the same material
as the first but it does include a scene
with annie potts's janine melnitz and a
quick look at the arms of what
definitely seems to be dr raymond's
stance rey appears to have some numbers
tattooed on one of his arms and jason
reitman told ign that the numbers
referenced the conversation about
judgment day between rey and winston
zetamor from the first film i remember
revelation 7 12
and i looked as he opened the sixth seal
and behold there was a great earthquake
for jason reitman's planned sequel
recreating the same look and feel he
remembered from the original films was
important with his father's connections
to the beginnings of the franchise he
had the resources to make it all work
the younger reitman went to great
lengths to replicate key details from
the 1980s for the sequel up to and
including finding the original letters
used to make the film's posters he
explained on bill burr's monday morning
podcast we went back to the work files
for the sound of the proton pack and we
went back to the stems of elmer
bernstein's score we went back and found
the original physical vinyl letters they
used to create the ghostbusters poster
in 1984. we shot physical titles with a
light and smoke effect because that's
how they would have done it back in the
day when reitman sat down with ign to
break down the second trailer he said
that instead of trying to mimic the
aesthetic of the original films using
modern day visual effects he and his
team went right back to the source he
said we actually found the original
special effects 70 millimeter footage
and scanned it we were always attempting
to go back to the original recipe and
recapture as much as humanly possible
that approach particularly applied to
the ghosts in the film the second
trailer contains a gang of mini stay
puft marshmallow men going wild in a
walmart a giant spectral version of a
terror dog and a skeletal ghost created
with a puppet meant to echo the taxi
ghost from the original according to
reitman he said there's nothing like
shooting with practical ghosts with
having something right there that the
actors can work with the biggest nod
comes in the form of new ghost muncher
who is similar to slimer and pays
tribute to the classic character reitman
said the original slimer was an angry
dude and very scary and we really wanted
to get back to that
a complete reunion of the original four
ghostbusters is sadly no longer possible
since harold remus who played dr egon
spengler in the first two ghostbusters
films died in 2014. his death was
devastating for his former castmates who
couldn't help but feel his absence while
filming the latest installment aykroyd
who co-wrote the original films with
ramus told entertainment weekly to have
that formation without that man standing
right there on the line with us was a
pretty serious adjustment he will be
very well represented in the new film i
can tell you that he's very honorably
represented spangler's family honors his
legacy in ghostbusters afterlife which
will end with a dedication to the man
who played him jason reitman confirmed
to empire magazine he said this movie is
for my father for my daughter and for
harold for a long time i had the idea of
a girl finding a proton pack in a barn
and i just didn't know what to do with
it when harold passed all of a sudden i
knew who she was it was egon's
granddaughter it became a spangler story
the 2016 ghostbusters reboot which
featured a title team of four women
sparked controversy virtually from the
moment it was announced some longtime
ghostbusters fans felt that the film was
somehow damaging to what came before and
a wave of social media vitriol followed
throughout its development and up
through the film's release jason reitman
had nothing to do with that film though
his father was credited as a producer
jason reitman's new ghostbusters project
is a direct sequel to the original two
films so it will ignore the reboot that
fact plus ghostbusters 2016 star leslie
jones's anger at being excluded from
future films meant reitman caught flack
in february 2019 when he said that he
was making an effort to quote hand the
movie back to the fans many took his
comments as an insult to the 2016 movie
and its cast led by women just days
later after hearing the response his
comments received reitman clarified his
remarks noting he had quote nothing but
admiration for the reboot and calling it
an amazing movie the director later said
that ghostbusters afterlife was actually
inspired by the 2016 film in a way he
told sfx magazine i think that the
remake proved at least to me the idea
that the ghostbusters could be anyone
and i expanded on this idea with
afterlife while always focusing on the
family aspect and the history that was
created by the original films
are you the ghostbusters actually we're
the conductors of them
yes we're the ghostbusters
dan aykroyd in particular has been
trying to get the ghostbusters series
back on the big screen years before the
2016 reboot and it does seem that the
door is now open to some ideas
those ideas apparently include a prequel
called ghostbusters high which acroid
has written as a potential feature film
that could launch a tv series
chronicling how peter rey and egon first
met as teenagers in 1969 in new jersey
though he was excited about the idea
aykroyd also cautioned that ghostbusters
high is just one of a number of ideas he
and the reitmans are exploring aykroyd
explained to the canadian press we have
other stuff after the jason reitman
helmed movie we have at least one or two
other concepts for the ghostbusters and
then we'll look at doing the prequel
which will be a perfect button on all
we've done up to that point in other
words if you like ghostbusters just keep
an eye out because we seem to be far
from finished with the franchise
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos but
your favorite movie franchises are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]